I want to know from you what this change
in leadership that Jack Dorsey coming
back in as the interim CEO says about
the future of Twitter's product because
that seems to be the problem hey there
tough year for Twitter to say the least
you know Dick Costolo what we're
learning now is he started talking about
this idea that he wanted to step out of
the role at the end of last year he
started seeding the idea with a couple
of board members and at the last board
meeting which was just a week ago he
said look I don't want to do this
anymore I think we've got the great a
great team now I've put together a great
team that's ready to execute on some of
these things and I think it is time for
me to step down I think me being in this
position has become a distraction to the
company so Jack Dorsey the executive
chairman somebody who lives and breathes
twitter is obviously the co founder of
twitter was CEO once a long time ago is
stepping back in take a listen to what
Jack said on the call yesterday about
why he's coming back one of the reasons
that I'm stepping into this interim role
is because of the belief i have around
our direction and our strategy
specifically around the product i have a
lot of context for it as chairman as
talking with the management team running
it and i do believe that it is right and
i don't anticipate any change in that
strategy or the product direction now
when he said that wait there's not gonna
be any change in the in the strategy or
product direction isn't twitter having a
lot of products issues that was that was
really interesting and and i don't know
if he was just trying to be supportive
of dick in that moment but there's a lot
of criticism not just from wall street
but from product people and from users
that twitter hasn't lived up to its full
potential Eric and Emily I know you
spoke to dick recently of course has
been so much pressure growing actually a
lot of people including Ben Thompson a
big Silicon Valley analyst and of course
Chris soccer who also spoke to writing
that stinging 8500 word critique calling
for Costello to go what did costlow
himself think about the pressure that
was coming on him to continue running
the company Chris Sacca by the way
wasn't calling for Dick Costolo to go
he's calling for Twitter to be something
better than it is now he says the last
five years have been lost
years there's been too much turnover too
many people leaving in Twitter hasn't
just gotten to where it needs to be he
said in that moment that I spoke with
him this was before dick resign he said
if dick costolo can can can figure out
some of these things that he's the one
who should be CEO and if not then maybe
Twitter should sell to a company like
Google or Facebook or or Microsoft I did
talk to dick costolo many times over the
last year about the pressure he's facing
as CEO take a listen to what he had to
say about that the board and I are
totally aligned the pressure is more
from you have a team you know you have
an entire company of people that are
looking to you to lead them and you want
them to you know you want to be
successful and you want to rally
everyone together and articulate the
motivation of why you have to be
successful and show them that those
efforts are paying off so that's where
the pressure comes from and the pressure
apparently just got two great Emily
there's plenty of speculation about who
might end up being the permanent CEO of
Twitter what are you hearing lata
reporting out there that Jack Dorsey has
always wanted this job back you know he
he punted on those questions when he got
them yesterday said look I'm focused on
finding the new CEO we did and he did
sort of outline what they're looking for
take a listen to what Jack Dorsey had to
say we're looking for someone who really
uses them loves the product in every
single way and and that is going to be a
huge huge attribute that the search
committee is looking for is that person
Jack Dorsey of course he loves the
product he lives and breathes it every
day we don't know but there is you know
a search committee the committee
composed of Evan Williams another
co-founder Peter fence and Peter curry
to Twitter board members they're going
to be looking inside and outside for
somebody to lead this company and we'll
see how that search evolves